yeah pulls back and reveals links
standing here his hair flopping in the
wind
he's like wink wink in LA alright so
they were location scouting for upcoming
Zopa video that's right you heard it
here first making a zelda video well
location scouting how do we find
locations we get asked this question
quite often
how do I find locations how do I not get
arrested when I shoot in the location
first start with you know your ideal
spot if you're familiar with like a nice
scenic overlook or a good park or
anything like that in your neighborhood
if a spot doesn't immediately come to
mind or you don't know Plano you're
looking for Google Maps works great
using satellite view Street view also go
and turn on photos so there's photos all
over the place that are geotagged with
locations and you can go you can kind of
see all the different spots people have
taking pictures in all honesty that's
how he's found the vast majority of our
locations I found this location by
googling we found our alley way for the
glitch by googling nightmare diamonds
are forever through googling so it's all
like we kind of ton of stuff through
Google Maps it's a great way to get
preliminary things out of the way so
thing number two that you want to deal
with with location scouting is
population density if there's people all
over the place you can have really hard
time shooting there unless you got
thousands and thousands of dollars and
you pay the police to stand around and
tell people not to walk in your set the
way we get around this is by just going
to remote locations we've always kind of
prided ourselves on the fact that we can
pack up our gear into backpacks for
hiking boots and go out into the middle
of nowhere is that almost like you're
you know hiking and camping most big
film sets don't quite have that mobility
and we do it's something we've developed
and we've worked on now when you're in a
city that becomes a little more
complicated but there's a couple ways to
deal with this one if you shoot on
Sundays usually everything's abandoned
in areas that are more industrial to
just take the time to explore you walk
around you'll find alleyways where
nobody's there you know it's tricky to
do in a city like such like Los Angeles
or anywhere else but those spots exist
you just got a yellow look where you
people don't expect you to look this
brings me to my third point if you
really want to have good flexibility in
locations and you want to be like a
gorilla Fela filmmaker you have to learn
to work with a small crew yeah like five
or six people and you're courteous and
you say hi to that you know your
neighbors that are around
we get other people's way if they're
walking by and just you know step number
one always being polite
you'll probably be just fine so I've
been talking about public land
you know alleyways parks that kind of
stuff put a lot of the areas that you
shoot crawl the armed public land in
fact a lot of areas that we shoot have
not been public land like for example
Assassin's Creed Daisy tether most of
those are on private land so what do you
do there well in all honesty
same-same initial approach google.maps
exploration found a cool spot it looked
pretty there's in the middle of nowhere
but it wasn't public land so what do we
do well we go back to Google Maps look
for the nearest house walk up to the
door and you knock on it then you go
hi mr. or mrs. my name is Nico I'm a
student filmmaker that one works pretty
well you also say local filmmaker we're
interested in shooting a small film we
were wondering do you know who owns this
land it's really scenic it's really
pretty we would like to shoot there and
sometimes the person goes oh that's me
sometimes I go no it's this person but
usually you can get the contact info and
once again if you just polite and you
assure them that you're not shooting a
Hollywood movie but you know it's you
know you and a couple people usually you
can get away with it just fine now in
places like Los Angeles where people are
really jaded about filmmaking kinda out
of luck but you just you know drive an
hour out of the city if you're looking
for a populated area there's still
populated areas that aren't in the heart
of the big cities it's really not
actually that hard it just requires a
little bit of charisma and a little bit
of people skills so another question we
get asked quite often is how do you guys
shoot with weapons and not scare people
or get in trouble when you're when
you're younger and you're out there with
your friends you know one kid has a
camera and the other guy's a gun and
maybe the other guy has a gun people are
probably gonna see the guy with the gun
before they said the guy at the camera
so how do you deal with that it helps
set at this point Sam and I are a bit
older we have bigger cameras we
generally have somewhat of a crew with
us and film equipment with us
so when somebody sees us the very first
thing they see is not a guy carrying a
gun we started back from here 14 and I'm
sure there's a lot of young filmmakers
that are watching this too and you guys
are a bit of a disadvantage the best
thing you can do is shoot on private
property whether your friend owns it or
you've gotten commissioned whatever it
is private property
is way way better than public property
in fact don't shoot on public property
with weapons just don't do it now if
you're shooting on private property
there's still some things that you deal
with
go around and talk to all your neighbors
around that piece of land and tell them
what you're doing and be polite and can
make things sound a little better than
they are don't go say hey I'm shooting a
gun fight with a bunch of terrorists you
know go and say I'm filming a film with
my friends it's about some soldiers in
the woods so we're gonna have some fake
weapons other just props don't worry I
just want to give you a heads up
call off your local police dispatch and
tell them that you're going to be
filming a film and say it mention that
you'll have some prop weapons and just
want to give you guys a heads up this is
really work for a city this is more for
like towns and that kind of stuff you
don't need to ask them for permission in
fact don't ask them for permission your
job is just to inform them dispatch
cannot determine whether or not you can
shoot a film at your house or your
friend's house or wherever you're going
to shoot and the last thing I can
recommend is don't make every video in
action video parents quickly get
concerned when other kids do is make
videos of them violently killing each
other with guns the more the more you
make other films the more you diversify
the less people are concerned when you
actually make a film with the gun in
there they go oh okay you know you'd
like to filmmaking this story just
happens to have be about soldiers or you
know an action hero or whatever shoot
and private land get permission tell
dispatch tell your neighbors and be safe
you communicate so now that we're back
in a place I'm reviewing the photos and
video that we shot on location obviously
it's important to bring a camera just so
you can record the scout you can record
the locations you visited we didn't
shoot a video board which is essentially
a storyboard which is just all the rough
angles for what we think we'll shoot but
you know you can test it out we can see
what's looking nice what's framing up
you know what good natural compositions
are in that scene and that matters a lot
because when you're there with the crew
and costumes and you're actually there
trying to film it you're hard pressed
for time and this is the chance you have
essentially figure it all out see what
works see what doesn't we shot this with
a pretty decent DSLR camera but honestly
you can use anything an iPhone you know
any small camcorders works because it's
all about just kind of testing out the
angles testing out the location for how
you think will go in the final shoot day
as you can see we have a lot of really
cool stuff here probably gonna use
a couple of these angles in the final
piece it's great because you can come
back and start actually you can plan
from home
you